Strom aus fossilen Brennstoffen oder
Atomenergie beides gilt als Klima oder
umweltschädlich
Braunkohle Öl Gas und Co sind außerdem
nur begrenzt auf der Erde verfügbar die
einzige noch nicht genutzte
Energiequelle die Kernfusion dabei
verschmelzen Atomkerne erzeugen Energie
ohne schädliches Klimagas freizusetzen
seit Jahrzehnten forschen
Wissenschaftler weltweit an der
hochkomplexen Technologie in der
kernfusionsforschungsanlage Wendelstein
7x in Greifswald haben die Forscher
jetzt einen Rekord aufgestellt auf dem
langen Weg zum kommerziellen Kraftwerk
ich bin mir sicher ich bin der
vollkommen überzeugt Fusion bekommen
irgendwann werden wir Fusion haben die
Frage ist ob ihm etwas früher etwas
später das hängt natürlich auch vom
Leidensdruck ab aber auch vom
politischen und gesellschaftlichen
Willen das zu tun wir Wissenschaftler
sind bereit
das Max-Planck-Institut für Plasma
Physik in Greifswald im Inneren die
kernfusionsforschungsanlage Wendelstein
7x nach ersten Experimenten im Jahr 2015
ist die Maschine drei Jahre lang um und
ausgebaut worden ein großer Schritt nach
vorne die Heizleistung wurde verdoppelt
neue Diagnostik angebracht 1000 Tonnen
Stahl spulenrohre und Pumpen
wichtigste Neuheit das Kühlsystem mit
flüssigem Helium mit dieser verbesserten
Ausstattung ist die Anlage seit einigen
Monaten wieder in Betrieb
[Musik]
wir haben es jetzt so zu 90% haben wir
es jetzt so im Griff dass alle Systeme
wieder laufen so wie sie vorher liefen
sind alle total neu total erneuert viel
neue Software ist drin viel neue
Steuerung ist drin viel Hardware alles
mögliche ist ersetzt und jetzt läuft es
langsam wieder zusammen und jetzt können
wir tatsächlich auch mit inhaltlicher
Wissenschaft beginnen Vorbild ist den
Forschern die Sonne Energie entsteht
hier durch Fusion also dem Verschmelzen
von Atomkernen auf der Erde wollen
Wissenschaftler diesen Prozess nachahmen
um in einem Klima und umweltfreundlichen
Kraftwerk zukünftig Strom zu erzeugen
ein hochkomplexer Vorgang mit Hilfe der
Greifswalder Anlage sollen
Rahmenbedingungen der Kernfusion
erforscht werden vor allem geht es um
einen Aggregatzustand den es in der
Natur auf der Erde nicht gibt Plasma ein
ultra heißes elektrisch geladenes
Wasserstoffgas hier erhitzt durch
Mikrowellenstrahlung dafür wird zunächst
dein Vakuum erzeugt ein Magnetfeld
verhindert dass das Plasma an die stark
gekühlten Wände kommt und instabil wird
Ziel der Forscher das Plasma bei 100
Millionen Grad dauerhaft herstellen und
kontrollieren zu können
wir müssen erstmal Energie reinstecken
und dieses Plasma dieses super heiße Gas
und das heißt zu bekommen und das ist
die Aufgabe dieser Anlage dieses Plasma
tatsächlich zu erforschen was die
Voraussetzung dafür ist denn im nächsten
Schritt auch Energie wieder rauszuholen
und das ist die Mission dieser Anlage um
Energie zu erzeugen ist hier eigentlich
zu klein aber sie ist groß genug um
genau diesen ersten Schritt zu machen
das ist der Witz
um Strom zu erzeugen müssen in großen
Fusionsreaktoren die wasserstoffsorten
Deuterium und Tritium zu Plasma erhitzt
und verschmelzt werden das
internationale Forschungsprojekt ita in
Südfrankreich will im Jahr 2035 mit
ersten Versuchen dazu beginnen
die USA forschen an einer anderen
Technologie nicht mit
Mikrowellenstrahlung sondern mit einem
Laser wird das Gas hier erhitzt im
dezember 2022 gewannen Wissenschaftler
erstmals mehr Energie als verbraucht
wurde
seit einigen Monaten läuft in Greifswald
eine neue experimentreihe zur Steuerung
der Anlage und zur Art und Weise das
Plasma detailliert und stabil zu heizen
aber Schritt für Schritt also
das ist ein bisschen wie so ein
nagelneuer Rennwagen wir sind jetzt bei
den ersten bei den ersten Runden die wir
mit dem drehen da fährt man nicht gleich
Vollgas alle bisherigen und die
aktuellen Ergebnisse der Experimente
sind hier im Data Center gespeichert
nach dem Umbau der Maschine kamen auch
für Leiter Axel Winter sehr viele neue
Analyse und Sicherheitssysteme dazu eine
riesige Herausforderung das sind 40 GB
pro Sekunde klingt jetzt auch erstmal
nur nach einer Zahl das ist so ungefähr
das was die weltweite Community im Jahr
2020 pro Sekunde zu YouTube hochgeladen
hat
das wird hier sozusagen auf diese
einzelnen Blocks gespeichert
zum Schutz sind die Daten in mehreren
baugleichen Räumen mehrfach gesichert
jeder Einheit hat ein eigenes
Brandschutzsystem allein das Data Center
verbraucht am Tag so viel Strom wie ein
Einfamilienhaus im Schnitt pro Jahr die
gesamte Anlage Wendelstein 7x benötigt
60 Megawattstunden am Tag dazu enorme
Kosten für Material und Personal
1100 Mitarbeiter sind hier beschäftigt
kritiker halten die Kernfusionsforschung
für einen Milliarden Grab vor allem weil
eine Kernfrage noch nicht geklärt sei um
Energie zu erzeugen wird Tritium
gebraucht in der Natur gibt es dieses
Wasserstoff Isotop nur sehr selten bis
er kann es effizient und den großen
Mengen noch nicht hergestellt werden
und alle Projekte die und und
Computersimulationen die man unternommen
hat um Tritium herzustellen die zeigen
alle Negative oder
reaktionsproduktionsraten von kleiner 1
das heißt die anfängliche tritiumzahl
nimmt ab
Tritium zu produzieren sei kein
Kinderspiel sagt Thomas Klinger weltweit
würde aber an Lösungen gearbeitet sein
Team in Greifswald hat in dieser
experiment-reihe einen Meilenstein
überschritten das Plasma hier direkt
durch eine Kamera im Inneren sichtbar
konnte bei 17 Millionen Grad 8 Minuten
lang stabil gehalten werden ein Rekord
der weltweite Goldstandard der ist sogar
einigen zehn Sekunden
und dann in den Kontext müssen wir diese
8 Minuten setzen das ist natürlich schon
heftiger Sprung und ziehen wir schon
zählen wir schon zu den einzigartigen
Maschinen auf der Welt für Klinge und
seine Mitarbeiter ist Kernfusion die
Alternative der Zukunft die
Strahlenbelastung sei im Gegensatz zu
herkömmlichen Atomkraftwerken minimal
die Stromausbeute könnte deutlich höher
sein als bei fossiler Energie außerdem
würde das fusionsfeier einfach erlöschen
geriete die Anlage außer Kontrolle
besonders wichtig werde die Kernfusion
wenn andere Energieformen an ihre
Grenzen kommen
sondern der Umbau der Welt
Energieversorgung ist eine
Jahrhundertaufgabe
Klinger schätzt dass das erste
kommerzielle kernfusionskraftwerk in 30
bis 40 Jahren gebaut werden könnte